ihr entgeht keine schmiererei irmela
mensah schramm übersprüht rechtsextreme
symbole und parolen wo immer sie welche
sieht bitte ein hakenkreuz weniger ich
habe es unkenntlich gemacht und das ist
für mich eine genugtuung
seit mehr als 30 jahren ist die 73
jährige berlinerin aktiv entfernt oder
übersprüht graffiti und kratzt aufkleber
ab aus überzeugung mit licht tun und ich
bin nicht wie ich will mich nicht
einreihen in die gruppe der notorischen
weg koka für ihr engagement wird sie
immer wieder ausgezeichnet zuletzt im
sommer mit einem preis für zivilcourage
doch dann kommt eine ganz andere
reaktion irmela mensah schramm wird
verurteilt vom amtsgericht eisenach
wegen sachbeschädigung zu einer
geldstrafe von 1050 euro
doch zahlen will sie nicht konkret geht
es darum in eisenach macht irmela mensah
schramm aus ennest ohne eine herz ohne
irgend jemand fotografiert sie und melde
dass der polizei am ende steht die
geldstrafe das amtsgericht eisenach
äußert sich schriftlich frau mensah
schramm hat keine parolen entfernt sie
hat parolen übersprüht auch dies erfüllt
den tatbestand der sachbeschädigung
der moralische hintergrund der tat wurde
anerkannt und floss in die
strafzumessung ein ja und was ist es
denn nun sachbeschädigung oder
zivilcourage oder beides da sollte man
toleranter sein
ja sie hat ja das buch gut gemeint und
nicht dass die alle hakenkreuze da sind
ja wie wort hat story macht eine schöne
aktion wenn sie hakenkreuze übersprüht
aber leider die strafe ist per gesetz
vorgesehen natürlich könnte man da
toleranter sein ja warum sollte man
diese hakenkreuze tolerieren also ist
doch eine gute sache wenn sie das
übersprüht oder mutter sie jetzt
bestraft wird über das finde ich
eigentlich nicht so aber als
beschädigung
das sieht irmela anders das gericht hat
angeboten das verfahren gegen eine
geldauflage einzustellen
sie lehnt ab klein bei geben sagt sie
wie sie nicht